hey everyone welcome back to another
episode of the water podcast i've got a
huge name on the show today with a big
big announcement but firstly shout out
to todd's racing one of new zealand's
great
harness trainers who's supporting the
podcast so go give todd's racing a
follow on facebook or twitter
he is an absolute lad also straight face
razors are giving waterlet listeners a
huge discount
on their super sharp five blade razor
and if you're in need of a new razer
then head over to waterlab.com and click
the straight face logo
it'll take you there with the lads
discount all ready to go
finally if you're listening to this
episode with some lad merch on or
drinking some more lad coffee
well then you are the ultimate lad and
thank you very much for supporting this
podcast anyway let's get into this one
[Music]
anyway guys it's announcement time again
this one has not been leaked at all
and it was a shock to me when i found
out but today's guest he's one of new
zealand's favorite lads
he's been on waterlab before he's told
his story of being in the fourth fifteen
at school
to becoming a hurricane legend it was
one of the most inspiring what a lad
episodes we've had today
so if you haven't heard it already go
back and listen to that but it's great
to have him back
on to talk about his future plans and
he's had a big decision that he's done
in the last couple of days and of course
like all my guests are
he is a lad and he's got some of the
best chat in the game it is
of course liam mitchell welcome chippy
gerber thanks for having me mate
nice to be back great to have you back
on i mean your
episode went down that well so many
people love
viral i heard viral absolutely viral
you're up there with bears actually i
think
you you and bears are right up the top
both most downloaded but what's been
happening post super
what have been up to nah back in back up
and palmy now i've been
had a few days on the tools here and
there apart from that i'm just
battling away trying to stay a little
bit on top of my fitness what tools
you've been doing you're back building
or yard barber
building that building i've only done
two or three days
nothing's nothing silly jammer loving it
still good something different
yeah yeah and how was the year how was
the year with the canes
it was good i actually really enjoyed it
it was a little bit i guess frustrating
didn't get as much time as i would have
liked or hoped but in terms of the year
itself i i really enjoyed it um
heaps of heaps of fun for boys so it's
the main thing mate you had some decent
cameos off the bench
as always bring outstanding work right
in the last 20 or 10 however long you
get
just bring those off the bench yeah i
think i got about five or six games
yeah i was grateful for those another
cat
we enter the cages about not starting at
all because i know when i was in the
coaches room oh the heat was coming from
you
nah nah not really not really sometimes
i'm
i asked if more minutes were coming but
they did it they did give me more
minutes towards the end which
i was pretty happy with yeah and the
team obviously not quite the seasons you
guys were hoping for i mean
that trans tasman was pretty close came
down to probably a kick in the end but
especially the altitude season was a
little bit probably disappointing
from your standards yeah i think that
i've said our season was tough for us
but
we came right like we had a big review
after that some serious
honest conversations in the circle of
death there but
um now we came right i think that
canberra game we got
pretty unlucky and if the result went
our way that game who knows we
we could have been there or there about
to the end as well so especially after
that reads game the boys put in a hell
of a [ __ ]
would you have backed yourself to win
the comp wow yeah you have to don't you
yeah you got to back yourself
no point being there
so talk to me about that circle of death
what what sort of combos went on
were you leading that child um no no way
i was out the back
scared little schmoozy no i wasn't
actually too bad we just had a review we
changed a little bit of our theme and
stuff
yeah it was quite cool it actually
wasn't too bad but
we just i think yeah i'm not sure what
happened up in the leadership group and
stuff but
yeah a few things changed like in the
environment just around the theming and
stuff which was
i think the boys bought into it yeah it
was good oh nice
and have you told the boys about your
decision do they
do they know you're not there next year
um
i think most of the boys i'm not there i
don't think many of them know where i'm
heading though
yeah did they do a presentation at the
awards night
nah nah so i still was in limbo
in the awards night so it was a beauty
result you have to get up and
do your leaving speech i think i have to
do three of those
thanks for the memories on the chat and
mitchell left the group
oh one of the greats so before we talk
about your decision tell me
like what were the what were the offers
did the canes offer you
an extension of your contract there and
what what other
options did you have um yeah they kind
of did
they sort of said that there's a spot
there they were just sort of waiting on
the npc coming up which i could
understand
um and i was sort of lucky in the
mindset where
i wanted some security i suppose
and i sort of just went for the security
rather than
like i would have packed myself without
sounding like a
cocky dude i probably would have backed
myself to get that sort of fifth spot
if it came down to that but i sort of
just went for the security and
yeah pretty much why i left yeah did you
want a fifth spot or
like were you happy being the sister not
really that was the other thing yeah i i
had a few conversations with alfie on
the phone back and forth and
i said to him i backed myself to sort of
get a starting spot or play some more
minutes but at the end of the day it's
just
one coach's opinion over mine so and
like whatever the coach picks for the
team i'm
i'm running with so yeah regardless if
it's me or not you know and that was
sort of part of my decision as well
at the end of the day i'll be playing
the best footy i can and if that means
having to hit offshore then so be it
and i remember a couple of times last
year you mentioned that
you'd be keen to go back to building you
were a little bit over
playing code was that ever an option
just giving up on the game and
going back on the tools or taking over
this yard barber empire
it was a it probably was a little like
in the back of my mind i wasn't too
phased about what happened because i
sort of knew i could go back
either to the farm or to the building
site so it was always kind of there in
the back of my mind but
deep down i probably knew that i wasn't
ready to go back just yet and i
i think i had a little bit more to give
i guess
but that was in the back of my mind yeah
that's probably why i didn't stress
about it too much
yeah and obviously everyone who's
listened to your um first waterlet
episode will know you're a gun tennis
player so
was there ever an option going to tennis
it wasn't an option
i'll work too many racket sponsors
[Music]
record sponsors down the drain so
anyway that's enough enough speculation
where is big chippy going next year
um off to palma italy and playing for
zebra
that's a huge shining for them they'll
be staked
yeah i'm excited looking forward to it
yeah what's your expectations over there
i've honestly got no idea i've talked to
a few boys about it um
yeah like i just don't know what to
expect obviously when i lived over
in spain it's it was a different time it
was pre-covered and
like the footy was completely different
so yeah i just i've got no idea what to
expect
in terms of covert and with rugby so
yeah
let's just get over there and see what
happens right and you absolutely love
spain too so you never feel them italy
yeah i'm looking forward to that is your
partner going over with you
yep yep she's coming she's coming yeah
that's going to be a big move for you
too oh
yeah 100 um she's looking forward to it
as well so it'll be cool
so what's the setup have you have
they've given you like a
accommodation a car is that is that the
sort of setup
yeah like um i think i think it was
accommodation in a car as well
um like i'm honestly not too sure i'm
sort of sorting it all out at the moment
so
yeah just winging it do you know who's
in your team dude
do you know anything about the side give
me something um i talked to the coach
the other night
i don't know i don't know a hell of a
lot about who's on the team or
um what the story is but the coach
seemed like a good bugger he was
an irish dude so he said most of the
boys speak english a couple of them
don't so
yeah i'm looking forward to it so
there's no kiwis there
that you know of i'm not sure i think he
said one of the there's a kiwi
guy over there who plays for italy now
but i'm not sure i haven't
yeah i haven't looked into it too much
sure you're just gonna go over there
with your suitcase and just
see what happens you're the most chilled
out this is the most chilled out rugby
signing in history
yeah it is
to go so i'm not going to get talking to
myself yeah in terms of that i want to
still
play well for them and see how well we
can go there
so what's the go there with insurance i
know a lot of guys who sign a contract
before a season that they're playing is
over um there's a fair bit of work that
has to go on behind the scenes
around ensuring that contract or things
like that what's the go there with you
yeah i think i'm not actually too sure
again but
they wanted me to go
i just got to hope for the best now they
um they wanted me to go
sort of now and i was keen to stay for
the turbos and then
they sort of i think i'm undone about it
and then
got back to us and said that yeah it's
all good to come over after turbo so i
think
it's just a fingers crossed game get
injured
fair enough yeah i'm sure i have to do
some sort of medical before i leave and
that you'd probably
know more about it than i would
whichever how that stuff works
what usually happens like you say you if
you're willing to risk it you don't
insure it but usually
insurance is pretty expensive if you're
trying to ensure a rugby contract
depending how many figures it is and i'd
imagine
yours over and um debris would be one
truck like zero
zero so many zeros
have you learned italian are you gonna
learn italian uh i've downloaded the um
the language app that i've done about
three times abby goes
ebby is on every night she's going hard
so please
someone will do something
yeah and how many years is it what
sexual contract is it just a one year
or it's a well sort of like a one and a
half year it's a
finish off the season after turbos and
then the full season after that
so i guess it's 18 i think it's 18
months it would have been a two-year
deal if i hadn't played this turbo so
yeah keem to get out there for the
turbos again and have you got plans post
that have you
have you thought that far ahead probably
not not not really
yeah we'll see how it goes i'm like i'm
keen to have a decent crack over there
and
play some good footy get some consistent
game time as the plan for the next 18
months yeah
at a decent level and then just see
where that takes me whether i stay there
or
if they want me back or if or if it
opens up doors come back home or
wherever wherever it takes me here i'm
i'm just keen to get some decent
consistent footy at a
good level yeah fair enough you're still
young
would you consider playing for italy
have you thought about that doing five
years over there and
potentially playing for italy at a world
cup or something
uh like i haven't thought about it but
if i love it after two years and the
opportunity arose who knows like
maybe that could happen but i i haven't
really thought about that
yeah good and you mentioned the turbos
how's the turbos looking this year
they've signed had a few good signings
eh
yeah i haven't actually met too many of
the boys that have um i've signed i've
i've met a few of them it looks like
looks like we could have a sharp side
there a few young boys and a few
experienced
ladies coming back so look forward to it
a few of the young lads been around a
few super teams in that
this year which is always handy yeah for
them to come back with a
i guess better understanding of the game
and that and where are you going to play
this yeah they're going to
be on at six or you're going to be in
the tight stuff at lock
i think i'm going to be a lock i yeah
well i presume i'll be at lock over and
talk to them
otherwise so i hope i'm a lock anyway
they're going to pick me first
man you'll be first on that team sheet
i'd imagine skipper
who's captain uh booth is i'm pretty
sure oh yeah
very dangerous yeah turbo's gonna be
right on happy days yeah
who's up first hopefully hopefully
that's the plan anyway
counties up first at home and then down
south to christchurch canterbury
i don't know if we play the mighty marco
this year no you don't actually
thank god for us
[Music]
oh yeah thank god for the marco
how good to see um red making his day
bill on the weekend oh
jeez that was a sight wasn't it and he
was on fire
he's a legendary oh
so good i love that guy how's the bucket
heads looking this year
are you do you still have anything to do
with that organization or setting that
group
up or making plans for them no i i
haven't had much to do with that for a
while
um like if i catch one that there's a
party on or something i'd drop them off
a
couple boxes of turbo juice or something
but i haven't
organised that for a long time surely
they get you back to a speech or
something for the voice
someone's inspiration back when um
antonio was playing kitty kitty was the
captain he came in and did a
buckethead prize giving one year at a
party dressed up in his
turbo's number ones and that came into
the prize gimmick oh surely that's you
this year
that's good stuff i'm not yeah i'm not
sure if that
surely it'll go ahead but i'm not sure
who will be running it or
what the story is there because there's
a bit of admin to it someone will take
the reins i'm sure there's a better
admin to it
hardest part is organizing a place to
host the house oh
true yeah you're pretty keen you're
pretty brave to
be willing to host the bucket heads i'd
imagine
yeah especially after that video of
your mate doing that trustful off the
roof i remember you talking about it
last time but
i hadn't seen it until you sent it to me
after the episode but
gee whiz that was loose stuff yeah he's
a maniac i think he's well and truly
retired from his [ __ ] head days as
well
with a broken bet
yeah all right oh good stuff
oh geez that's good to hear about that
decision chip but as always we've gone
to our instagram for some questions and
i sent it pretty late so i didn't get a
huge amount but a few are coming through
right now
oh here they come here come the bucket
heads
so many so many okay first question
actually a couple about this are you
bringing back the yard barber
where is the yard bar but what's
happened to it uh since i went back down
to wellington and like
locked down and that all came sort of we
came out of lockdown and
the level three stuff um and we started
training again full time i sort of
didn't really have the time
to do it so i haven't really been doing
much and then winter came round
and i wasn't a fan of doing it then
either so i haven't really picked it up
at all to be fair
that's a summer job yeah it's a summer
job
but now i'm going to be going into my
third wow second winter in a row so
would you think about setting it up in
italy during the summer
jeez i'd love it yeah that'd be massive
on it
water blasted decks and stuff i don't
think there's much grass
around there but and they're like sounds
and stuff
yeah that's true you don't want to have
a backlog palmer
yeah just maintain their pot plants
you'd be good at that
okay next question would you rather be
an all black or takawa
president yeah all black
i thought there must have been some sort
of insight into that one but now
just testing your loyalties to the club
yeah yeah yeah if it was the
all black or a club like competition
that would be probably a bit closer i
reckon oh sure what to win the comp for
them
yeah yeah i played in my first semi on
the weekend which we
unfortunately went down to but that was
still pretty cool true
so um yeah you'd probably hate being a
club prezi
way too much admin too much
man i hate edmond
okay this one would you rather make 30
passive tackles or five dominant
five dominant will probably get me in
the team
you definitely rather make 30 a
that's you're a workhorse 30 pesos three
passes will get me um
the super coach captain so that'll
get their voice on fantasy points that's
the one for the fantasy
lads yeah yeah about five get you in the
team you're right
that's is that was that always still the
feedback this year
you need to be more dominant pretty much
uh yeah pretty much yeah
okay next one which hooker throws the
best darts in world rugby
[Applause]
oh um i'll say rocket sally
riccitelli oh wow bolter
and the world he does throw a real nice
start though right
i do a lot of work with him in his um
hallway he's on his knees strong seeds
probably every every second or third
night so
yeah as long as his um eye socket's not
fractured
and he can
[Laughter]
okay need more buckethead stories
obviously in the first episode you told
a couple of
buckethead stories everyone loves it
have you got any more for the woodland
listeners
maybe one more buckethead story would
just cap it off with america
half the issue was every time i went i
was so blind that
i can't even remember the score of the
game i was let alone what happened
before the game
uh um
i probably shouldn't even tell the story
there was one when we were marching to a
game and one of the boys threw a
bottle that landed clean on a roof of a
car
and um there's probably like 20 or 30 of
us
and these this car pulled over got out
it's like a tire iron
and just chased us all down the road
that we all scampered like a little
mountain out of there and we all just
sort of ran
ran to the stadium and then reunited at
the
stand there that was a pretty loose one
i don't know when i was playing when i
was playing we had a good win
i can't remember who was against and the
bucket had stormed the field i think it
was one of my first
games in the bucket edge on the field
that was pretty cool to be playing and
then on the other side of it
i was still my mates and that was still
full noise so
security matched them all out i think
few of them got kicked out and stuff
which yeah
it's always good to see yeah it's crazy
you went from being the buckethead
president to really
playing in a year one of the great
stories all the boys
charged the field to celebrate with you
oh yeah they're special
all the lads all the lads i think it was
my first start we played waikato and um
at home first game of the season we bet
them then they ended up winning every
game since and won the comp that year i
think
oh how about the bucky it's got yeah
okay last question throughout the whole
waddle ad season one and two i've asked
pretty much
all my guests for one piece of advice
but i never got one piece of advice from
you
so leah mitchell the man with so much
advice
what is the best piece of advice you've
ever received
this will be good um
probably from my pop who told me to pull
my socks up and look like a rugby player
[Music]
life changing life changing
always slap my socks up no i don't know
that's a [ __ ] one
i was about to say it was potentially
worse
yeah like what have you been getting
there
oh well you want something cheesy or oh
you give me whatever whatever it pulls
on your heart
give me something from deep down and
jeffy let the real chippy out
oh i got nothing
i honestly don't know jabber how did you
go from
how'd you go from the 415 to a pro 40
something must have happened something
inspiring some of us have told you
something
look i honestly float i've honestly
flipped it
you just got lucky get like how did you
get lucky
no i literally just got lucky in terms
of um
the boys first 15 went on a uk tour and
i played
so they wasn't they had to pick a whole
other like under 21st place or colt's
place playing this under 18's 102 team
and then
from there i just sort of clicked on
through the grades but
there was if it wasn't for the boys
higher going on that tour i would never
have been selected in the 18th team
but no one's ever told you good who
knows i'm probably have but
what do you want to hear like train hard
go to school
only if you believe it no
i don't know i guess just being told to
believe in yourself i suppose
there we go easy as it sounds yeah we
got somewhere let's get it
we got somewhere there now let's
potentially turn to the best advice
believe in yourself there we go
there we go listeners believe in
yourself look look where chaffey's got
from the fourth fifteen two becoming a
super rugby legend and about to take
over european rugby over in italian
mate what what a journey looking forward
to seeing you play over there
obviously firstly um with the mighty
turbos
looking forward to getting back out
there making few dominant tackles and
leading the turbos to success and then
obviously
heading over to italy and just showing
them what liam mitchell can do over
there
playing against some of the best players
in the world it will be good
beauty i look forward to it thanks for
having me jabba
no worries mate appreciate it you're a
[Music]
lab
[Music]
what